alors oui jacques rivette
oui je raisonnais vous poser une
question à propos de sacha guitry
voilà vous avez dit que dès qu'on parle
du théâtre au cinéma on est dans la
vérité du cinéma parce que au départ il
n'y a pas d'autres sujets que cette
question de la vérité et du mensonge
c'est une formule de falaise vérité
mensonge eux sont des mots extrêmement
vague et flou auxquels on peut faire
dire beaucoup de choses mais je crois
qu'un désert un des intérêts de sa
salive sacha guitry c'est d'avoir
justement toujours eux montré que la
vérité des souvent là où on pensait qu
était le mensonge et le mensonge là où
on pensait qu était la vérité est que
dans son jeu de ce qu'on appelle théâtre
filmé il a toujours mis deux semaines
pourrait dire vérité entre guillemets du
côté du théâtre est ce qu'on appelle
mensonges du côté justement du fait de
le filmer
il ya une revendication continuelle
cherry tree salle d'une parole tenue
jusqu'à ses plus extrêmes conséquences
ce qu'on pourrait peut-être
dire à ce sujet c'est que autant que je
sache les pièce de guitry était écrite
d'un seul jet je crois qu'il écrivait
toutes ces pièces dans une sorte
d'écriture automatique c'est peut-être
ne se sentent pas le mot exact qui
contiendrait mais quand même une
écriture extrêmement rapide et qui le
on a l'impression sourire à la lecture
enfin de quelques pièces que j'ai pu
lire que quand il veut commencer à
écrire le premier à qu'ils ne savaient
souvent pas quel serait le dernier acte
et que parfois c'est quand il estime
qu'il en a assez long pour occuper la
soirée il fait tomber le rideau et que
c'est effectivement cela donne dans les
grands moments de ces pièces soit dans
les monologues soit dans certains
dialogues qui sont en fait la plupart du
temps des espèces de monologues à deux
voies ça donne une sorte de parole
errante et vagabonde et dont on ne sait
jamais où elle va déboucher et qui
d'ailleurs ne cherche pas à déboucher
quelque part il en tout cas au point de
vous deux sur les rangs sans fin est
frappante dans les pièces elle est
frappante aussi justement dans dans
certains des scénarios qu'il a écrit
directement pour l'écran pour ce que
vous dites sur le caractère quasi non
prémédité les directions de prennent le
personnage c'est un petit peu ce qui
confirme un guitry et ses personnages
comme des joueurs parce que jouer c'est
par définition ça c'est évident ce sont
des décès des pièces et des films sur le
jeu dans tous les sens du mot ça c'est
je crois qu'on n'est pas les premiers me
dire ça mais c'est également justement
des joueurs qui trichent comme il l'a
souvent plusieurs fois souligné
ce sont des joueurs et des tricheurs
c'est à dire ce sont des vrais joueurs